[Music]
when i turned 16 i had a little party a
little birthday party sweet 16.
yeah oh i made it was a big to-do
i got uh a gift from a friend of mine
it was a french newspaper called
lamonde he just gave me
a newspaper a french newspaper i think
because i had mentioned to him that i'd
studied french in seventh and eighth
grade maybe and he just brought me
without it it wasn't wrapped or anything
it was just like a newspaper it's both
weird and thoughtful yes yes that which
is prayer yeah
yeah but years later it ended up
paying off for having some value
when a couple days ago
christian and i were watching jeopardy
the championships and one of the
questions was
this is the newspaper in france the
answer was what is le monde and none of
the three champions got it and i got it
and i was so proud of myself and you
were sort of impressed do you think this
story classifies as a brag a humble brag
or just a regular brand um let me make
it humble by saying it was the only one
that i got right that nobody got right
so it was a humble brag it was humble
bragged
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening life is short i'm your
humble braggy host justin long life
could be a dream sweetheart
this is my uh i need no introduction oh
wow that's my braggy
uh
brother that's how you do it that's a
braggy self introduction yeah but you
said it sarcastically so that that's
that's true maybe that is a humble break
i do think humble brag it's a brilliant
uh concept that's harris whittles came
up with that term great harris whittles
one of the funniest um
and i god i used to love those he had he
had a twitter account that was devoted
to humblebrags and i remember sometimes
some friends of mine would would be uh
mentioned in them uh
guests on the show
um
humble bragged uh were caught humble
bragging and of course i just did it uh
it happens but have you found though
that it is misused often
yes like very misused yeah it's usually
used humble brag now to describe a brag
i agree yeah and humble true humble
brags are it's a really funny concept
but it's rare it's hard to it's hard to
have a good humble brain i kind of want
to look up some um
there was one i remember oh i there was
one that was like i'm gonna bastardize
it but it was like uh i have to go to
the golden globes tonight i hope i don't
i'm presenting at the golden globes i
hope i don't trip on the way up to that
because i'm such a spaz i'm a klutz
yeah but the real information is i'm
going to the golden globes right that's
that's funny
it was such a great term i used to think
and then once i once the term was coined
by harris um i then became so much more
aware of it uh in life you know then i
especially with the onset of social
media it became so much more apparent
with social media because people started
doing it all the time and over doing it
and overdoing it yeah um so why are we
talking why are we talking about your
16th birthday well a gift you got on
your 16th birthday that paid off 25 25
years later is that that is cool i will
say that's cool i
i didn't mean to belittle that story and
call it a humble break it's actually a
really good story well just because all
that time it was it had become this
thing that i was a question mark in my
life like uh that i didn't i rarely
thought about but like it was an odd
thing for a kid to receive
16. i see i thought i didn't know the
bad story that i didn't know that you
had been given this gift and that's how
you got the answer right the question
right rather yeah um so
when you celebrate it when you got that
right in jeopardy all the other three
got it wrong
you acted as if you just uh won a golden
globe
you were like very proud of yourself but
but now it makes more sense to me why
you are so proud of yourself no it
should make less sense i shouldn't have
been that proud it was something that i
had it would it makes more sense why you
would be um
it was noteworthy why you'd be excited
yeah yeah because it's the coincidence
is exciting right it was this thing that
had finally right that it paid off after
20 years and i didn't know that right i
thought you were just
celebrating too much well that's one
thing you got right right but it was
also exciting that none of the other
champions even buzzed in that tournament
was crazy that was great that tournament
made i haven't
felt so dumb and
i was in school i know not that i was
dumb in school but i remember the
feeling of feeling dumb in school when
you didn't know something or or you're
taking a test and you're like not
prepared for it that feeling that
feeling would be that feeling
that feeling i haven't had that feeling
in a long time wow that's humble braggy
that's true okay
or just braggy
um
humble about it yeah there is because
you're saying you're humbled by
how little you knew uh
in in that tournament you know as it
relates to that that's true compared to
those three champions that's true those
guys did make me feel really really
uneducated they humbled you they humbled
me they're so smart
okay here's a good one um
uh this is from adam levine wow we got
mobbed at the airport i think they
thought we were at justin bieber
that's a really good one a good a
classic good one is is like this guy
just hit on me well like yes and when i
was coming back from the gym yes i
forget
like i i hadn't even showered yet or
something yeah i remember that yeah i'm
trying to remember specifically who it
was this is a good one i just stepped on
gum who spits gum on a red carpet that's
great well
why are we talking about i don't know
humble brexit uh well we shouldn't be we
should be talking about birthdays that's
true why are we talking about birthdays
because
our guest today
shares a birthday with you june 2nd my
birthday is june 2nd 1978 as you all
probably know
and his is a year earlier june 2nd 1977.
our guest today is
my friend and the great actor zachary
quinto
zach or zack as many of you know or
spock as many many of you may know him
in the updated star trek movies he's a
great actor he's done amazing work in
theater i saw him do who cares what i
saw you may have seen uh you may have
seen him in heroes yes hit nbc show
yes which i think is getting remade and
it's called shiros
um yes heroes and he was in american
horror story he was in you know it was
great we don't talk about margin call he
was in that movie he was good on that
you know uh i think it's fair to say he
is star of stage and screen i would say
maybe screen and stage because people
associate him first but that's not a
saying but i think he
prefers theater i do too so
you know what you're right agree to
agree to disagree star of stage that'd
be a funny humble brag who was like oh i
just read i just read a bio written
about me and it said star of stage and
screen don't they know i've done less
stage work than screen work yeah that's
a little sloppy real good humble breaks
make it sound like
they're not intending to do it it's so
subtle it's it's got to feel like that
they're not trying that's why the the
adam's one is it's great yeah yeah it's
like it's really clean it's clean it's
just like brag let me try to defuse it
with a being ah yeah um so he's in a
show now called he's called nosferatu
but it's spelled differently it's
spelled like a uh if you saw like a dr
license plate spelling of nosferatu n-o
i think so it's
strange right it's a strange choice well
but i think a vehicle factors in and and
they didn't want to just call it
nosferatu because nosferatu would
i i think betray what the show is really
about which is nosferatu the original
notes maybe they don't have the rights
to it oh
you're right
can you get away with that like could i
call something uh dracula
yeah don't think so
maybe maybe maybe there's a way around
that i don't know but the original
nosferatu you had not d were you not
aware of i knew the name nosferatu i
never knew what it meant oh yeah okay so
yeah i think it was the original vampire
movie so zachary's playing a version
it's not so much a vampire he's but he
he preys on kids souls um so it's very
dark and he's playing this uh villain
part we'll talk about it in the
interview but zach and i have known each
other for a long time and and because we
share a birthday we always
end up i always get a text from him and
vice versa on our birthdays it's just i
don't know why that's your birthday
buddy yeah you have a few birthday
buddies right i do i will brady is a
birthday buddy but i don't know him i
know but he's still a birthday buddy
yeah dana carvey is a good birthday but
so far i like all of my birthday buddies
i haven't met dana carvey or wayne brady
but i'm a huge fan of danny carver yeah
who are your birthday buddies uh i have
no idea what yeah
i don't know one person that shares the
birthday with me
oh hey you got some good ones i do yeah
idris elba whoa yeah cool macy gray
that's cool that's cool uh country
singer david allen co and uh swoozie
kurtz one of the one of the most fun
names to say huh swoozie oh and lil xan
who
you know
little zanenberg
i'm not familiar with his uh i'm not i'm
not friends with him so i don't
diminutive xanax
[Laughter]
um that's interesting that you you
weren't aware of that that's cool idris
elba and lil sam
anyway my birthday buddy and i hadn't
seen each other in a while and it was so
good to catch up with him he's such an
a thoughtful introspective wise wouldn't
you say he's got like we'll find out
okay all right so let's do it um coming
up next
my
chat with my birthday buddy
uh
the very talented very kind zachary
quinto
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
do you want to work now are you hi
as the kids say yeah i've never really
felt so um
so excited about just what the unknown
yeah isn't it great it really is yeah
and i and i haven't really allowed
myself to uh
to drop into that in a long time had you
ever been on a show for a contract that
was longer than two years heroes was
four oh heroes that was like my kind of
first big job and that was four years
four years that's an odd amount of time
right it sort of fell apart oh
it was meant to be longer i don't know i
mean it was meant you know that was in
the the late aughts and the writer
strike happened and it sort of
interrupted the flow of the
process and then when when it came back
it just never really had never really
achieved that same level of quality yeah
i remember though it had a rabid
following still i mean like
internationally yeah it's crazy how many
people are still conventions and stuff
uh you must get destroyed at those
conventions yeah i've done a couple i
don't do that very often but but even
just when i'm traveling internationally
like people
overseas really have a strong connection
to that show and yeah i roll on it so i
i had this idea of you today i was
slightly late it was like 9 59 we were
supposed to meet at 10. i'm not telling
you this because i know you know this uh
so i was outside at 9 59 i got this text
that i had to respond to i was like [ __ ]
something tells me zack is going to be
perfectly on time and i ran in and sure
enough it was like 10 o'clock sure
enough the sign-in sheet said zq yeah 9
59. and the guy was like so i put jl
and the guy goes no no no you have to
sign your name really yeah okay he
mustn't have caught me putting my name i
don't think he did uh you looked less
suspicious than i made me i don't know
actually
you really break it down but do people
think i don't know why then my
perception of you would be that that you
would be very punctual and i wonder that
if it's subconsciously because of spock
oh spicy is delayed he's not going to be
late at all
it's not logical i like to be on time i
hate to be early um but i i think i'm
pretty punctual i definitely i have a
pretty good sense of how to get around
the city as well and i know this
neighborhood in particular the travel
time from my house to here is like very
consistent oh where's where do you live
i live in uh
the address yeah the address is uh i
live sort of in between the east village
and the west village and
down that way okay because i run into
you all the time or i used to do more
my ex lived in
uh
yeah and i used to live on ninth street
and fifth avenue which is right there so
that was why we saw each other a lot
back then yeah those were the days
oh yes
i missed them um but you were born in
pittsburgh which i don't think i knew
and i had the same day as you a year
later i knew that you're before you oh
believe me that's mostly what we're
going to talk about great
i love it yeah a year before each other
every birthday i'm 77 you're 78. i know
i'm such a narcissist that you're one of
the only birthdays i can remember people
that i know there are so many of us if
there are who are dana carvey dana
carvey i don't know i wish i knew yeah
wayne brady yeah um
dennis hazenberg oh dennis facebook
that's right uh fabrizio moretti who
fabby dated uh we both dated this oh
yeah yeah right yeah um there's other
people too i can't really think of right
now but it's like birthday buddies oh
andy cohen
that's right
yeah so we're declaring you must run
into andy a lot i do yeah yeah i don't
mean because you're gay because of the
of the neighborhood proximity totally um
in but also because you're gay uh
yeah you're stopped did i just come on
you know what's funny is that our my
brothers i do the show with my brother
and uh his girlfriend maggie we were
watching i really want to get to this
because my i've recently discovered
billy on the streets oh right and i
can't stop watching i mean it's funny
it's so good i knew billy for i knew
billy before billy on the street
actually from where did he i feel like
he was
[Laughter]
he does stuff in uh the poconos doesn't
he put the dinner theater in the pokemon
we met through mutual friends like
probably andy cohen
cohen um yeah but yeah before billy in
the street when he was doing um he was
doing a live show
maybe i'm making this up but i'm pretty
sure that i did the live show in l.a
with julie white oh yeah he used to do
it right a live yes i met julie white
who's one of my favorites with robin
taylor didn't he do a show with rob
that's how i met him through robin lord
taylor yeah um
lord taylor robin is such an unassuming
guy and i love that lord is part of his
name
right robin and then those guys both had
such a um
an emergence into really exciting
careers i'm so happy for both of them
they're really lovely so that's how you
so once he started doing the show it was
uh of course i'm your friend at the live
show and then he was gonna sell billy on
the street and he knew that i had a
production company so he he reached out
and said you know could we get coffee
and just like can i pick your brain
about you know
these op like these these places that i
could take this show and what your
thoughts are and so we
had coffee and i just sort of gave him
my two cents and like obviously he
didn't need it because he just is
killing it and like made the best choice
for himself and like built this kind of
really solid foundation on
his humor and then that segwayed into
other i mean i just i love seeing that
with people that i knew before it
happened yeah i bet and and when they're
able to mine
the best parts of themselves creatively
uh it's such a simple consequence
hilarious
but it's so well written and it's
actually kind of more
complicated when you unpack some of
those so and the social commentary that
he's doing yeah
yeah he's really uh
i think a really insightful
yeah comedian um you were you were born
in pittsburgh i my brother writes these
questions sometimes and he goes uh he's
such a dick you were born in pittsburgh
and raised in the suburbs and he says
cue your pittsburgh accent because i've
been uh dude i've been doing a
pittsburgh accent and i did this netflix
series where i did a slight um
pittsburgh accent they said i did well i
played a guy from pittsburgh his
father's a gangster in pittsburgh and
they said wait what [ __ ] why don't i
watch this well it's that's a good
question yeah that's a good question
that was my next question why didn't you
watch my show what show is it it just
came out it's not it's called
girihaji it's on netflix it's a bbc
co-production so
i'm not like in the in arrears of why
like no it's not no
even people in the loop well let me and
then i think the more important
questions let me hear your picture well
it was it was there was uh i had two
days to prepare so i didn't go like i
didn't go like full yinz zero excuses
also as you know yin's guy is over there
you know if that's the phone the phone
call i gotta make a phone call over
there phone call phone call you don't
know you don't know your house yeah so
it goes like
yeah no i grew up downtown like you know
totally going down to steeler games and
uh
stiller games diner by the mall i would
go up the mall with my friends after
school school and we'd go down primanti
brothers and get you know sandwiches and
coleslaw they put the coleslaw right on
the sandwiches that are so cool
onions guys go over there and hang out
in there that's i will totally be your
that's another coach for season two oh i
wish well unfortunately i don't want to
spoil anything
it's a really unique sound i've never
heard anything like and i and i had it
actually like i actually had a
pittsburgh accent as a kid really yeah
before my voice changed uh there are
these like videos of me being like hey
how are you doing it's so cool um and
then uh my voice changed and i went to
drama school and they beat it out oh
i don't have it anymore but i can still
do it oh that's it's you sure can it
because it's it's very unique oh so you
went to and you went to school in
pittsburgh
yeah uh one of the best acting schools
uh did they when they told you you had
this accent were you even aware of it
uh
i don't really yeah i don't really think
that uh your voice had changed by that
my voice had changed by my freshman year
of college um thank god but i you know i
think it was just part of the training
like i just think it was it was only
after like years later when i would see
videos of myself as a kid that i noticed
that i had it like right right
do you still have family in pittsburgh
is that another appeal
oh no actually anymore really no
you're you have one sister and a brother
your brother no sister um
apparently gender non-conforming i think
every more is a sister
don't know him that well but what little
i know about
and and so he's so there's no you have
no like more ties there uh i have ties
there but none of them are familial it's
interesting i have
i have a uh
my teacher that lives in pittsburgh that
i you know that i see and friends and
stuff but i don't really have family
having spent time there i remember uh i
was there for st patrick's day and right
on carson yes jesus yeah
so there's for those of you who've been
there it's bar tattoo shop bar bar
restaurant you know it's crazy i've
never seen it was like a zombie invasion
of like a drunk
burger
what was that like
i didn't have that experience of
pittsburgh it was very my my experience
was very suburban and very uh was the
air quality cleared up by then oh yeah
yeah yeah pittsburgh went through a
renaissance in the 80s um and
you know it was a huge steel town yeah
and and there was a lot of pollution and
you know i'd heard stories last year
evolution there was like you know layers
of soot on everything yeah but it really
evolved pittsburgh as a city it's a it's
a great place i mean it's very safe it's
very the people are really
great you know there's a real kind of
salt of the earth working class
mentality there but but it evolved in
its um in its industries and and so when
the steel industry
died essentially it uh it found
medicine and technology
um and of course education there's great
universities it's great museums great
museums but it's it's kind of
recession-proof so like in 2008 because
of medicine and technology pittsburgh
kind of weathered the recession in a way
that i i think was surprising to a lot
of people oh that's interesting yeah so
it's a it's a cool city to come from to
be from yeah but obviously it's not the
kind of city that you
would stay in if you're serving any sort
of larger scale ambitions you know in in
unless it's insane right
now or a museum if you love museums
curation i remember going to the andy
warhol museum and i was i love the
entertainment of me too and they took us
um kind of behind the stuff that they
had yet to curate fully i'm sure you got
that behind the scenes thing
and there were all those
boxes
and i said well what are what he said
they got taking us on the store and said
well these are just boxes of
stuff
yeah
yeah he really did right like tissues
and like
used condoms yeah i mean stuff
i feel like
i feel like uh
that my favorite part of the indie world
museum actually is the collections of
his personal effects that are kind of on
each floor as you come off the elevators
in in like little
yeah you know curios or whatever i love
that i love that and sometimes there's
like a little doodle of like keith
herring's that he just left it when he
was scribbling down a phone number
actually um
we grew up almost exactly at the same
time and i remember as a kid growing up
in the suburbs of connecticut yeah
being gay or or knowing gay but that
wasn't a thing that i was really even i
was not aware of um and it it wasn't
until i went to college really that i
met where did you go to college
so then it was like hello couple of them
there they were very yeah mostly
um there was like people were like
what's heterosexual
um was that your experience
yeah for sure yeah yeah there were i
mean i did start performing as a kid
when i was about 11 so i was i was
kind of suddenly immersed in a world
where there were more gay people and but
i was really resistant to it and i was
really conditioned by my social and
particularly my religious upbringing to
um
to not really you know open myself
catholic yeah
yeah
that must make it
i mean exponentially
yeah really [ __ ] up yeah yeah you know
because because my family is also pretty
religious and involved in the church and
i went to catholic school from
k to
fourth grade then i went to public
school from fourth to eighth grade then
i went back to catholic school for high
school and yeah and even if it's not
like an all-boys private catholic which
high school as a gay man i'm sure is
like good and bad yeah i mean i would i
don't know what it was i mean it was
what it was yeah i i
as a gay person i came of age during a
time when you know it was radically
different from what it is now and so you
know i didn't really come out until i
was in my 20s wow officially i mean to
my friends and family and uh and then it
was another seven years after that that
i came out publicly so there was a
longer process i think of of coming to
terms with it for myself and integrating
it and accepting it and then sharing it
with people well you're also that's
interesting i didn't know it was so
late but i don't think people appreciate
people younger people appreciate how
just different erratically
entirely different yeah landscape now
which is amazing you think about it um
yeah and and i and i see it all as a
continuum you know
that that my experience was facilitated
by the people in the 30s and 40s and 50s
who you know couldn't even conceive of
living an authentic life and then the
people in the 80s and the 90s who are
ravaged by the aids epidemic and you
know every step of the way and every
generation
allows the subsequent generations to
have an experience that is um
different and ideally better right um
and i think that's sort of what we're
seeing now in a radical way which is so
exciting sure yeah we had bobby burke on
and uh i recently discovered the show
queer eye and uh he was saying just how
and i don't think i appreciated how much
that first show the queer administrator
it was one of the first times you saw um
that gay people become part of a
mainstream um
then there's on the flip side i would
imagine not wanting to be defined by
even now like talking about it now i'm
like
i feel like you are so much more than
that as as an actor as a person that i
and i'm sure we'll get to the point
where like it won't even be discussed
it's like uh well i don't know about
that i mean yeah we probably will but i
don't think for a while because i think
what's happening socially and then
what's happening in our industry are two
different things and i don't think that
i don't think that in the in the most
fundamental way um well i i should be
clear about it i mean if you look at the
trans movement for example and the
representation of trans people in our
industry
um that's one of the most exciting
things that i think we're seeing right
now um
uh you know candace kane who was one of
the first trans actors who was on when i
was doing heroes she was on dirty sexy
money
and i met her through that experience
and absolutely
loved her and you know she really
um was a pioneer in that way you know
for people like liver and cox or hunter
schaefer who you know is have you seen
euphoria no
that's amazing but this comes up all the
time i got to see it
yeah it's fantastic but you know so
that's really exciting um
i will say you know as a gay man
i do think that there is because um
homosexuality in men i think is so
inextricably tied to masculinity
and masculine identity and masculine
representation in the media
i think that our journey is unique in um
in the ways that it's still restrictive
and in the ways that our representation
um
is more defined by people's um by
people's uh prejudices and um yeah well
i think that's why your role in this
journey and this narrative is so
important um as is neil patrick harris
is because i don't associate you with
any sort of superficial trappings of
being gay i don't i hope that doesn't
sound offensive but you spock is not gay
a lot of the roles you've played have
nothing
spark is a poonhound yeah
yeah i didn't realize until i saw that
documentary that leonard nimoy's son i
saw that last night and uh i don't
really i didn't realize how he was such
a sexual uh like oh spark i can't yeah
oh yeah crazy for sure um you know i
look i feel like
my sexual orientation is one aspect of
you know a a a complex and um
wide-ranging
um
personality and and and experience of
the world and and i and i've worked to
integrate it i've also worked to not be
defined by it you know and and and yeah
and we're going to cut all this out
but were you afraid when you did come
out that like professionally that it
would be like oh i won't get to play
these parts now i mean honestly for me
there it just didn't matter at that
point when i decided to come out
publicly in 2011 i i
the balance was too shifty in the
direction of needing to do it there was
just too much at stake for me to really
care about what it would do to my career
i just this was at a time when like a
lot of teenage
um lgbtq guys were killing themselves in
public and you know very it was like
very much in the news yeah and it was
just there there was just too much i
didn't feel like i could any longer yeah
have the experiences i was having and
not be authentically you know who i was
yeah it just wasn't fair to those young
kids totally and was your mother was she
how did she take it well i'd already
come out to my mom seven years earlier
i should come yeah
to everyone in my life it wasn't like i
was hiding yeah yeah and acknowledged it
with words probably
um we were talking about spark and and
this to me is
really defines your range your
versatility as an actor because spock is
uh
it's not that he is emotionless but you
said something interesting in this
documentary which is like they're just
different parameters within which i have
to work well yeah that's true which
which i think is must have been an
incredible challenge how do you first of
all how do you define those parents
those emotional parameters and and how
much do you resist using leonard nimoy
as a blueprint for that
i mean i i tried to resist that entirely
um i was so fortunate that he was
supportive of my casting and really
available to me for you know as i was
preparing for the experience he and i
became
he became like a father to me in the
last decade of his life i mean we were
incredibly
close um
uh and i'm still you know very close
with his widow and his family and like
i'm that they're like you know wow i
adore uh him and them and uh and so i
had access to him and
but i i mean performance wise though i
was really resistant to kind of um
and jj was really clear about what he
wanted us to do which was like you know
we're we're coming in with
with respect but also with our own
perspective well everything about that
movie was different than the series yeah
you know i mean so so it wouldn't make
sense to change the sets and the effects
and
and not change the performances sure i
guess yeah yeah and i think we all came
at it from that perspective of um we
want to honor who who originated these
roles but we also want to make them our
own sure yeah then leonard was you know
incredibly supportive of that and was in
the first two movies and you know had
you ever heard before you that those
movies came out that you you look like
him
[Music]
not i don't think explicitly or not that
i remember but now my experience is so
kind of inextricably tied with right
it's hard to get out yeah that i don't
really remember what happened before
maybe but um
but someone did reach out to me that's
how i found out that they were doing it
like somebody who i knew
you didn't know jj going into it nope no
i had i had been doing heroes and
somebody somebody sent me an email or
something and was like hey i hear
they're doing a new star trek jj's doing
a new star trek movie you should play
spock and i was like oh wow like i
wasn't to be honest and i've said this
before i really wasn't a star trek fan
at all
we'll definitely cut that out yeah i
mean i'm i'm i've said it before you
yeah i wasn't either too much yeah i
mean we our generation is very much star
wars oriented but
um but you know jj
was somebody who i had obviously been
acutely aware of and
um and i remember like uh maybe
a year before that i was reading a an
article about him in the la times and i
just remember thinking like i'd really
love to work with him like he just
seemed so
and so when when i got when i found out
they were doing this and i was doing a
lot of press for heroes and
and everybody kept asking me like what
do you know what do you want to do now
like heroes like what do you have any
you know any dream roles and so i just
started saying uh well i hear they're
doing a new star trek movie i'd love to
play spock no way that's amazing kept
saying kept saying it oh you like willed
it
well what happened was april webster who
was casting the movie had caught wind of
that and
when they started casting she reached
out and called me in and i was the first
and only person that they saw for the
role you're kidding but i think it was
like the timing the fact that
heroes was kind of in that world yeah
just like like it was literally like the
explosion of heroes was just kind of
happening and to the point right out
there a lot totally you know it's the
one where i thought jj abrams was a part
of heroes um
so star trek i can't believe it wasn't
an arduous process it was just an
audition oh right yeah no i mean it was
super weird i went in for april webster
i remember this vividly i went in and i
can't believe it's your first movie yeah
it was my first yeah my first movie for
you know my first movie of record right
i uh i went in for april first
movie yeah i went in for april webster
on a sunday it was uh
i'm not like super like i just remember
it was april 15th 27th 20 2007
and i and i read with her you couldn't
um you weren't allowed to take the
script or the side you know it was all
very sort of so i had to go in and
uh
and read the script or read i don't even
know if i read the whole script i think
i might have read no i didn't read the
whole script i only went in to read the
sides like a couple of days before the
audition that's right they're very
protected super protected but i just i
just sat in the room and it's like a
sniper basically i just sat in the room
and transcribed the script into my like
a notebook so that i had the lines that
i could then go home and work on them no
they wouldn't even let you take any no
they wouldn't take any paper from the
office so i like went in and they're
like you can can be in here for however
long whatever so i like wrote it down
and then i went home and worked on it in
a couple days it went back and it was
like a page and a half it wasn't even a
big scene yeah wow and we read and she
directed me a couple of times and then i
was leaving uh i was leaving the country
for two months to go on a trip i left
like two days later and i was just on
personal training uh it was like a
hero's press thing and then i attacked
on another month of travel on my own
afterwards
by myself and visited friends in europe
and went around and i came back
a week before my 30th birthday our 30th
yeah my 30th birthday
and uh and
when i got back they were like jj wants
to meet you
i met jj um
the day before my 30th birthday and i
got the job two days after my 30th
birthday so it was very like yeah right
and i had been away i had been traveling
really thinking about it really yeah
wow yeah i i it's also amazing that you
thought to do that to transcribe the
it's really smart really i mean i was
like well all right i need to yeah
you don't want to get those lines live
long and
[ __ ]
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello
[Music]
do you have any similarities to that
character well yeah i mean sure very
content i feel like yeah i mean
there's a there's a kind of and this
isn't only true spock this is actually
true of
a number of characters that i've played
i think there's a kind of internal life
that isn't always completely apparent or
accessible you can sense it i don't know
well i think it's accessible i i it's
not it's not on dis
yeah you it which would make what makes
you an interesting actor and and which
was what was great to see about american
horror stories that you got to then
stretch i think and and find mind
different
elements of that i mean you know it's uh
it's definitely the the sort of internal
duality of spock right the internal the
sometimes it's conflict sometimes it's
just tension sometimes it's just you
know integration but yeah there's an
internal kind of i'm a gemini
so i have a kind of dual there's like
two aspects do you feel fine
you do oh yeah because whenever i tell
people uh you know what's going on
yeah oh my gosh
i get some version of this response i
say oh i'm a gemini oh boy you know i'm
like look out i don't get it but i but i
love us my joke is always like i don't
know what that means what the [ __ ] does
that mean great that's a good joke
because it's i mean i feel like for me
it manifests in uh
there are there's a very there's a very
outgoing part of me that's very sort of
extroverted and
and then there's a very sort of you know
internal and and private and solitary
part of me and and sometimes i inhabit
one aspect of myself more than another
and and i think that is
attributable at least in part to my to
my gemini nature yeah this might be
an obvious question where does the more
outgoing part when does that come out i
mean is it that just socially like at
parties and stuff at parties when you're
wasted
i
uh
yeah i mean i think it's i don't know i
think also at this time in my life i'm
more sort of i've integrated the two of
them a little bit yeah i used to be a
lot um they used to be more separate and
they used to be sort of
socially or you know i loved to
party i love to be out and to socialize
we've had some of those years together
um i've actually been sober for four
years oh good so uh that's really
changed and i've found does that make it
easier to integrate those yeah yeah for
sure yeah i bet yeah
um so so i think that's also part of the
um
the experience oh good yeah what was and
and if this is too personal to please
let me know what was the impetus for
that isn't that why we're here yeah um
that's too personal
i'm gonna i know that's what the show's
going to be called now you know i was
sorry if this is too personal yeah good
new title you know in my late 30s i was
drinking more than i did in my 20s
uh-huh uh i was high every day all day
weed yeah yeah yeah too much weed for me
yeah i just was smoking all the time to
the point where i was like oh i'm
actually not even getting high anymore
i'm just burning my lungs yeah
and this is kind of before the vape
revolution really you know so i was
really smoking a lot wow i just i just
felt like i was so unhappy in my life
and i had absolutely no objective reason
to be unhappy yeah and i just stepped
back and there was just a moment where i
was like
this has to change and i really you know
i really examined it for a long time
i think i tried to talk myself out of
believing that i had a problem or that
it was
not you know normal but it had a problem
and it wasn't normal and you know now
you see the difference you see that
clearly now god wow crazy good for you
insane just the
freedom and the clarity and the
gratitude i mean that was the the
essence of
my situation was that i had lost a
connection to gratitude entirely
entirely i had no
ability to be grateful which which must
be difficult someone in your position
because you have so much to be grateful
completely i had a you know really
robust
work life
beautiful home life i had a lot of
things you know around me and i just i
remember saying why aren't i happy yeah
why can't i be [ __ ] grateful
and uh and i think that is one of the
things that i've come to learn that you
know an over dependence on alcohol and
drugs will rob you of is is the ability
to be grateful yeah yeah it's funny i
don't often associate weed with being
having any potentially negative
consequences like that i i just yeah but
you're right i mean i think weed is well
you know
yeah we could go so many different
places like if you were to go back to do
you ever think like well i could only
smoke weed occasionally do you is that
well i did that for a long time yeah i
would be like oh i can't i have to stop
drinking so i would stop drinking i'd
have you know i'd have a shot glass of
rolled joints on my desk that i would
just smoke all day
uh wow or i'd stop smoking pot and then
i'd be like oh you know it's five
o'clock let's open a bottle of wine yeah
so i i would i called it my shell game
for a long time i would be like well i
can stop this but i'll do so i had tried
that because it just didn't work it was
too intrinsically linked to i mean they
were too much a part of the same beast
yeah yeah sure so do you
do you miss weed do you miss any aspects
of it um
no i mean
i i couldn't at this like sitting here
right now and
this could change i suppose i have to
allow for the possibility of it but i
literally could not imagine a scenario
in which i would feel like it's a good
idea or or you know
a pleasurable idea to to drink or smoke
again um it's great but that you know
who knows where it goes it is it is a
process and it is but
was it affecting your work
it was affecting my spirit spirit yeah
so that effects
is directly linked to my work and how i
show up to things and so yeah yeah you
know it was okay certainly
i'm ha that's great zach that's good
together it's been a really uh profound
journey
damn that's great
is your bro are you close with your
brother i am yeah okay really close yeah
where does he live he lives in um reno
nevada
he's older he's older he got married um
a year and a half ago his wife is from
his wife's family's from reno so they
moved closer to them and i went there
for christmas it was beautiful and oh
that's nice spent time in you know
they're very near tahoe and sort of race
they have kids no yeah do you think
about having kids yourself i do in the
next couple of years
i don't know
i mean it's complicated i feel like as a
gay man
there's part of me that feels like oh
well i'm not genetically predisposed to
procreation this is a controversial very
spock thing to say it kind of is yeah
it's it's also controversial people sort
of get when i say this people like
that's crazy you know but you know we've
we've come so far in medical and
technological advancements that you know
people can just have kids in whatever
way like let's just do it yeah
but in this world that we live in i feel
like like bringing a life into this
world when it's not part of
you know my genetic imperatives feels
counterintuitive on some level yeah i
get that but then there is the you know
the of course the very human desire to
want to to have to pass on
genetic lineage yeah
so i don't know yet how or
when or where or with or adoption or
adoption or you know but
but i the more i think about it now the
more i feel like because of the world we
live in it is um
incumbent upon people whose
consciousness is uh expanding to
actually bring children into the world
so that we can
prep you know perpetuate an expansion of
consciousness rather than the ignorance
and yeah you know the qualities that i
think are plaguing our culture and other
civilizations this movie called
idiocracy and it almost be like
idiocracy is about how just the opposite
of that where people who don't have that
kind of
elevated consciousness and and uh sense
of compassion they're having
in your position are like you know maybe
we should wait and they hem and haul and
then it becomes too late it's my
meditation teacher who who shared that
perspective with me and really changed
my whole kind of position on it you know
and then there's the very
selfish kind of like i i love my life
like i love my freedom i have like i'm
entirely untethered at this point in my
journey
and something about that that feels
really cool and then i go hang out with
like my beautiful amazing god children
oh my god and then like after four hours
i'm like peace out you know and like i
watch my friends and they're raising you
to the choir like you know what what and
like i have friends who've been like
don't do it oh my god why would you do
it like i know most of my friends you
know it's like that's tina and billy
madison
no
stay young
i know i know so there's a lot at odds
in terms of that yeah
but i don't need to decide this minute
no that's one thing that we're lucky
about now you say you have a meditation
as gemini's we don't have to decide
because then we'll have a totally
different decision lately right a couple
minutes later yeah you have a meditation
teacher i do uh did that start with the
sobriety it was yeah it started you know
i got initiated um i got initiated uh
yeah a few months after i got sober but
i didn't really develop my practice uh
until the beginning of 2019
uh and circumstances in my life led me
to a place where i just found myself
consistently meditating not just
intermittently you know and so then
through that my practices deepened and i
found
i found my way to another lineage which
is adjacent to tm
and uh and and in that lineage i found
teachers and and and uh i've been like
really kind of deepening my experience
on that which has been amazing and again
you you feel
a great deeper sense of clarity and it
helps you freedom and you know um yeah
it's been it's been really
really powerful good and really
incredible people yeah are you
meditating no but i
i keep i want i have this and people
i've i've just heard the the most
profound things about its effects
well tm is how i got into it but then i
found my way to vedic meditation which
is uh it's essentially it's the same
exact technique
um it's just um it's just cognized by a
different teacher right so tm was
brought to the west by maharishi
mashiyogi in the 60s and most i think
probably famously was the beatles guru
and jay gurudev
is from the lineage of um of maharishi
when he was in the united states uh he
met this kid the 16 year old kid named
tom knowles who was an american born in
arizona and um and tom
found his way to maharishi and then he
just immediately became like his like
student and assistant and traveled with
him and lived and worked with him in to
various degrees for 27 years oh my god
and then
went off and sort of you know started
teaching as the maharishi instructed him
to do and there's an organizational
hierarchical quality to the tm
organization that doesn't exist in the
vedic organization where they consider
themselves a community right um and and
who's the yeah the guru of that
particular lineage is very much alive
and you know travels and so i just you
met him yeah yeah i just found for
myself
that there was an immediacy and a
vitality to that path that i just wasn't
finding in
the other side and you know and and the
vedic path welcomes anyone who's
initiated into tm
you know
i got my my mantra from the team
organization but then you know was
welcomed with open arms into the vedic
organization so with the mantra that's
you you have the same mantra then yeah
ah no kidding yeah i i know it's the
same really yeah oh how do you choose
your mantra you don't it's giving it to
you
um but yeah so so so so tom is the the
guru of that lineage and then i have a
teacher who i work with on a more
regular basis and one-on-one yeah wow
yeah so it's been really it's really
changed my whole life in pretty
incredible ways i appear to have happily
share you with you like the i would
definitely you should just check it out
because you know there's that thing of
like oh well
and i felt that for a long time like i
was just how do i do this yeah yeah it
seems impossible 20 minutes twice a day
you know i got to watch the batch learn
whatever but yeah no it's um
it's really it's really possible and it
actually really
um i would like that that really opens
up a lot yeah bandwidth it's interesting
that you only recently started doing
this because i it seems like you've been
meditating since you were two you're
such a meditative
that's a voice compliment i wish that
were true but um but you know i did it
intermittently as i said like i did
there was a period in my uh in my late
20s that i was sort of
exploring it but i've just i've never it
never took root yeah the way it did and
was your initial interest in it did that
have any you say your late 20s was that
did that have anything to do with how
different your life was becoming or at
least how different people were treating
you because you had achieved some risk
it was actually before i achieved uh any
level of real measurable success that i
found my way to um to trying to meditate
because i was in so i was in about and
it's interesting if i think about it in
terms of my sobriety i can remember in
my late 20s right before i got heroes
i didn't work for uh actually uh so
notorious got cancelled
and between then and when i got heroes
was about seven months of just
absolutely no work and i was
horribly depressed sure that's
all the time and and at that time in my
life saturn returns like there was a lot
of shifting and transformation going on
and yeah i didn't have the context for
it and so i
i started meditating then but um and
then and then i got heroes and i was
like woohoo like yeah
but yeah i'm really grateful that i
found my way back to it in this
uh iteration yeah yeah you do a lot of
work with the trevor project too um
it relates to spark in the sense that
spock was such an
outsider is such a an icon you know yeah
because people really identify with his
um
alienation no pun intended um you know
and his sense of
duality yeah people feel like oh i am
this thing inside and and and how do i
relate that to the world i really
understand it um so yeah no it's
definitely i think it's an apt
comparison can you talk a little bit
about what the trevor project does how
people can donate um yeah the trevor
project to me is one of the most
powerful nonprofit organizations that
i've ever experienced it's a 24 hour 365
day a year
suicide prevention hotline for lgbtq
youth and
when i came out publicly in 2011 the
first call i made was to the trevor
project i had donated to them over the
years
quietly yeah yeah totally yeah
i've done like trevor live with them and
yeah but yes i i um i reached out to
them um the organization and said you
know now i can be a part of what you're
doing not just sort of
donate to what you're doing and so i
went in to meet the
the ceo of the organization and the
staff and i ended up actually
becoming a lifeline counselor and going
through the training oh wow and being on
the phone
with them for for
holy [ __ ] the better part of a year
after i came out yeah
how what is that like
i mean it's
uh you're actually on the phone yeah
yeah yeah i like answering the phones
and uh you know i mean it's
probably one of the most like humbling
but also empowering experiences yeah
i've ever had just like really
understanding the power of the
organization and you know i mean we ran
the gamut from talking to kids who are
confused yeah or giving kids resources
for community um services to
having to keep kids on the line while we
contact emergency services to go
get them out of the car that they lock
themselves into in a parking lot you
know where they're about to kill
themselves
you know it was a real you never knew
when you answered the phone what it
would be wow
and we're talking about this in this
these are kids in america which is like
among the countries in the world
probably far more advanced in terms of
tolerance and gay you know acceptance of
of
homosexuality than
most countries well sure i mean in terms
of you know first world development yeah
i know of course i mean if you're
thinking of
but you know but also there it depends
on where you are geographically you know
yeah you have to turn their calling from
the middle of the country where
you know the they might as well be in
sure right all these other places yeah
again socially not necessarily
politically right our political like our
law right
you're right aggressively against them
but the but the social constructs you're
right
legally we've made some real progress
yeah you know under the previous
administration um yeah which is another
connection that we
right
for uh
for obama in both elections right yeah
we were in chicago together when we got
reelected that's right of course how can
i in fact i have a great picture of you
um of us with
i think we're either in front of
biden either he's photobombing you and i
went to like the back room after obama's
speech to meet
biden yeah yeah we had a threesome with
byron
that's right
[Music]
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
the show nosferatu is is
coming out soon right the second season
yeah the first season is aired uh that's
an amc amc yeah i think you can watch it
on hulu now you can uh and then the
second season will come out probably in
the summer i imagine we're on the same
schedule okay and uh the the one thing
that really struck me besides how fun
and kind of campy the role must have
been um
was uh because you played such a great
bit
dylan but but you said something
interesting about um which is something
we've explored on the show with actors
is finding the
humanity and the goodness uh or
in this character and this character is
like close to being the devil i mean
he's like basically he's a very evil
yeah he is it's based on a novel by joe
hill hill right
who is a great author stephen king's son
um and a great author in his own oh i
didn't know that no you didn't yeah
steven's son and uh i went to school
with his other son owen oh really yeah
um yeah joe um wrote this book and we
adapted it into this series for amc um
it's uh and you play a guy who collects
souls of kids yeah they did to stay
alive he's a vampire he's 135 years old
um and he you've tried this really cool
old call 1938 rolls-royce viii yeah
amazing it was cool to drive um
yeah i mean i it's interesting you know
i
i just finished um
last week the second season of the show
and um oh so you didn't shave your head
again no i didn't shave my head i shaved
my head the first season like with a
razor jesus it was for you know five
months a real
um was that for the prosthetic just to
make the wigs they had to wear a lot of
um aesthetics yeah so i just they
the conversation was like that will make
it easier but it was horrible for me
personally and then so this year i was
like we're not doing that and i also was
this year like you know let's not we
don't need to do as much of the
prosthetic stuff so i did it early in
the season and at the end of the season
but the middle bit i didn't do it as
much which was great yeah um because
that really was um much more challenging
than i expected going into the second
season the first season was one thing
but having to do it season two you do
ten episodes ten episodes so how long
does that take to film something six
months four and a half months oh oh
that's not good it's so bad yeah
yeah
um uh you and you play you you do a
great old you play an old man
that was one of the things that it feels
like sounded incredibly and and also
you know i hadn't done television in
five years actually
and so i thought like oh let me go back
and do something that i know people like
to see me do yeah yeah and and that was
um
and i thought you know it's this this
opportunity to kind of immerse myself in
this transformation and yeah but
ultimately i just felt like it was there
were things about it for me i loved the
people i loved the creative energy
behind the show
but just fundamentally
it's territory that i had trod before on
a level that really became challenging
um to feel connected to in a way you
know and so i'm really like i feel
really excited to explore other things
now moving forward and to sort of maybe
a play i'm excited
to get back into yeah i bet you're so
good on stage
um okay these are going to be quick oh
but there was a creator on that show
named tom brady yeah tom's great do you
ever tease him about uh his name yeah
yeah for like the first week and then it
got old
but tom's great do you know tom no no i
just thought it was a great writer i
want a really great guy i mean i'm not a
huge sports fan
i was like oh isn't that isn't that a
running back
i think we mentioned him every time on
the show because he's it's also a funny
person to be named uh have to share a
name with because he's also such an
impressive physically yeah for sure
what is your most commonly used emoji i
like that question this guy
oh it's holding up his hands like sorry
or like uh what can i say
like the guy in the blue shirt that puts
his hands up
the wink
oh sure the wink now the first column is
the wink the guy holds stands up the
heart the smiling purple devil
and the guy that's sort of like going
like that like side smiling yeah side
smile
also wait do you do the um do you have
the ones that look like you no the
advanced ones no my friend hasn't just
ones let me see the advanced ones are
pretty good
no how do you do that you just make it
you go over there and you like design it
to look like you but i think it's a
pretty good likeness i like that on your
likeness you you did a black hat that
will always work
oh really and my sunglasses yeah since
when since you were a kid no i don't
know just since like
breathe like lately
since i made that emoji you often wear
black everything too i when i run into
you i do i like yeah really my color is
navy to be honest oh really yeah i'm
today i'm wearing all black but i but
you fooled me i wear navy you're billy
on the street appearance too is all
black no that's navy it is once again i
will
i will because i want to rewatch the
whole season too um if you'd be a
professional athlete you you don't care
about football we know uh what sport
would you play um
you must have been were you into sports
growing up no no
um
i'm like very not into sports
what would i be
i don't know uh was your brother you
never played my brother was super into
like he was he's much more
we compliment we're like opposites yeah
we really connect in the middle like um
he's a really soulful person but he
expresses things in a very different way
how how what's the age difference seven
years seven years
so and
your father passed away when you were
seven you were seven now so he must that
fourteen yeah so it affected us
differently yeah i was still really kind
of in the gravitational pull of our mom
um
rebelled more so i was still home for
you know
whatever long yeah
college but i also went to college in
pittsburgh so that sort of made my
relationship with our mom more intense
and complicated and he sort of pulled
away more from her and like you know and
expressed himself differently he was
very outdoorsy and invisible and i was
more sensitive and
emotional so that didn't necessarily
make you closer
but also when my dad died you know my
brother had to become the kind of man of
the house and a little bit more of it
like he was he was very very sweet and
did the best he could and you know
stepping into that role particularly
with me
um you know i remember vividly him you
know having to be put in the position to
kind of
not be a disciplinarian but you know
enforce things with me and like how
sensitive he was to that and i really
appreciated that but it wasn't until we
were adults that we became very close
yeah and now we're very close oh good
yeah and so did you see shades of your
own dead in leonard nemo you had
mentioned he was a yeah yeah for sure
the parallels were very very you know
interesting and um strange and yeah
that's great yeah physically and then
also otherwise i bet what a blessing
yeah it was um if you could have so
sports not no no
yeah come on okay
bocce we'll see
if you could
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life hummus hummus do you
have a favorite hummus sponge there's a
hummus now that's like a new
that i just discovered i think it's
called ithaca
and it's like my favorite new hummus
okay flavors great consistency maybe
they'll be a sponsor check it out it's
like a hummus it'd be illogical not to
sorry
you're just like so disappointed
what's your favorite what's your
favorite movie of all time oh you know
that's a
terrible question oh you're the same
somebody alec baldwin said the same
thing well i asked him
that question yeah and he got actually
mad at me like not even like he wasn't
even like he was like how dare you ask
me that question like do you know how
many [ __ ] movies i've seen in my life
like how could i possibly narrow it down
to one that's funny i gotta say that was
amazing uh so what was it anyways he's
like lady in the trap if i had to pick
one
i did that instagram challenge uh where
you have to put up the your 10 movies in
10 days without a caption or whatever
yeah
i've narrowed it down to
um
some which i could probably like now
that i'm back on instagram i can just um
let's see i get it now i gotta follow
your uh we'll do this at the end okay
um i
put up here in no particular order
um here we go
uh the talented mr ripley the hours ill
pastino mr ripley yeah okay
no no great these are not again a no no
no
no
no
oh i see uh a chorus line talented mr
ripley there i just followed you know
uh
harold and mod uh wit
wit wow do you know that no i've never
seen it but it's a play right it was a
play yeah and then mike nichols made an
hbo film of its tearing emma thompson is
one of the most moving
powerful okay uh spirited away
silence of the lambs flirting with
disaster and magnolia wow a real
cross-section of movies those are my
favorite ten films ah magnolia yeah i
remember being really struck by that
when i saw that such a good movie yeah
that was one of those experiences
walking out of the theater i felt like
i'd been hit by a car oh dare you you
and come here she's so [ __ ] so good
she did that on billy on the streets you
know
did you ever see that ever seen her
episode oh god it's so good she did
billy has her do that to you it's a
stranger are you serious that monologue
no how dare you you come in here
and she's such a beaut
such a beautiful crier
um yeah well just the whole like jason
robards movie phil hoffman like oh the
gang
i had never seen phil do that to mine
how sensitive he was yeah contender and
tom cruise phil parma yeah and uh bill
macy and everyone's the whole anyway
what a what a great [ __ ] i want to
see that again yeah um well i'm glad i
asked you now yeah well you got you got
more than you bargained for that yeah
wit i gotta watch wit and you know what
this is embarrassing to invent
you've never seen harold and mod what i
know
but if you had to live somewhere else uh
marrakech
oh wow really yeah so you've been uh-huh
and loved it oh
yeah wow okay did you shoot there did
you no
just done it you travel a lot i do huh i
love to travel
where do you want to go that you haven't
been in india oh yeah yeah i was
supposed to go to they're supposed to be
in india now actually um but you decided
to do this instead of to come here and
be with you no i was supposed to go to
india uh
and then i couldn't because of my work
schedule and the show uh nosferatu which
just you know overlapped by a couple of
days so i couldn't make the trip but uh
i did just get back from iceland iceland
for 12 days for uh the holiday for new
year's wow yeah it was
mind-blowing so cool wow so so cool you
gotta go
wow but if i had to live somewhere else
it would definitely be
okay in
the marrakesh well okay um who's your
favorite muppet
um
that you identify whether you find the
most entertaining gonzo oh
huh yeah i love gonzo yeah it comes with
great arms great great yeah great arms i
also love beaker i also love animals yes
very different types of all different
yeah
um if you could have one superpower it
would be invisibility uh-huh great yeah
uh yeah good um if you had to be one age
for the rest of your life physically
um what would you pick knowing what you
know now you you could have all the the
mental three yeah yeah
um if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal
an owl ah i can see that yeah
and that makes sense yeah i really love
it
um meatloaf the food you could you could
choose one of these to have you could
you don't have to have it all the time
but you could have it whenever you want
and you can't have the other one
meatloaf the food or meatloaf the singer
didn't mean if the singer just like oh
global warming yeah i got to stop
mentioning him he did it
was really disappointing that came after
greta thunder yes that's right
[ __ ] me love the singer oh god um
dogs are cats dogs yeah
beetles are the rolling stones
beetles
i've never asked anyone this but have
you i was gonna say star wars or star
trek have you have you come to have a
new appreciation for star trek i mean of
course yeah i mean of course i feel i
feel a sense of
allegiance yeah but yeah you can't even
answer that star wars fan and i think
you know
i'm all about cross-pollination now what
is it like when you go to those
conventions how
have you had i'm i'm sure a lot of the
experiences were positive but i've only
done a few um
yeah it's you know it's totally fine
yeah it's really fine yeah they're very
like i just did one in london uh last
year and uh you know i do maybe one
every two years or so yeah just to kind
of like have an experience and totally
when you i was thinking about this last
night uh when i was watching that
documentary when you found out that you
got the part
did you get emotional when you made that
hand gesture when you made that sign
i couldn't do it at first oh really i
needed to like train my hand to be able
to do it i still can't do it in my right
hand what oh you're a lefty i'm a lefty
oh my god i'm looking at zach now it's
really strong in the movie where we had
to glue my um
my ring finger and my pinky finger i can
kind of do it but like not reliably i
can do it on my left hand oh wow spock's
left-handed when i play him um i'm
it'd be funny if that were like the main
emoji that came up on your phone i do
how great is that i have my own yeah
that i really do use but i don't think
it's in my uh
you're my favorites i'm very judicious
yeah i bet yeah you can't be throwing
that no no no no it's too
self-referential um
do you ever think about your are you
still
catholic do you ever do no what are
there any catholic remnants uh uh
in terms of your understanding of
metaphysics or anything like that do you
have you taken any of that into you no
no i mean i i went you know i was very
involved in the church growing up i went
to catholic high school i was a youtuber
i was a lector i was an eucharistic
i was an altar boy i mean i did
everything wow and then the minute that
i graduated from high school i never
went to church again really no
wow no
i did it because i had to to the to the
disappointment of your your mom and mom
yeah yeah yeah totally but you know i
just i have a different spirituality
yeah i value the i value the um
tenets of the catholic
philosophy yeah but i believe the
institution is is too
hypocritical and and you know just the
sexual scientists alone and particularly
the
you know the the
sexuality of catholicism and their the
repression the repression your ethos now
sounds more in line with like a hinduism
or like a i was telling a pen basically
he's a baha'i pen pen's gray
i didn't know he was married he's got a
step kid now no i had no idea who's he
married to
um kathy bates
yeah
i can't believe you didn't hear about
that
kathy bates is seven months pregnant
yeah yeah it's a miracle
um
he uh
that's how thirsty she was for do you
know
yeah
you know this term thirsty thursday of
course well i just learned i'm not i'm
not a caveman justin
i mean i was on instagram for eight
months but i'm not you know dead well
instagram is how i learned
i just learned this body picture
and how would you use well in what
context that thought would you call
someone a thought i'm that thought yeah
oh you're that hoe over there
i guess you wouldn't say i'm that
thought you'd say i'm thought yeah i am
that hoe over there and we're too old to
be
um bless us but but i didn't get on
board with stan
no that's right i can't use that i can't
i stand with somebody and
well that's all from
i just danced
i met kathy bates you know she's in that
american horror story universe but we've
never worked on the show together right
um but i met her at a dinner like we
were having dinner in the same
restaurant and i was sort of like very
aware that she was a few tables over and
was like oh man there's like kathy bates
you know and
she and and i just never imagined that i
never occurred to me that she would know
who i was but then i thought like after
the fact oh yeah well we both come from
that right
yeah she was so
incredibly
think she's so talented i'm nice happy
for her and her number you know this
richard julie haven't seen yet but it's
great she's great in it um always great
i know [ __ ] always great yeah i love
her oh yeah she'd be someone i'd be
intimidated to go up to because she
seems like brash and like what are you
doing like yeah and like no nonsense
like she could see through any kind of
uh ass history right but i just love her
yeah what's next the oh the boys in the
band is coming out on netflix yeah
directed by the great joe mantello who
have you worked with him i did years ago
at williamstown a landford wilson play
and lanford was that one he was
obviously still alive
it was called the hotel baltimore well
you did have it yeah yeah with rockwell
playing the judd hirsch part yeah uh
sarah gilbert was my sister lois smith
was oh [ __ ] great get back dan baker
still let you have it lois smith she's
an inheritance right now oh that's right
she's she she's for those of you who
don't know she's uh low smith is great
after she's east of eden and uh five
easy pieces i think incredible actress
um but there's a great podcast with her
and josh hamilton
having a conversation um
so joe directed you did the play
directed the play and then we made a
film of the of the of the story as well
directed that too i'm so glad because
the first movie he directed in 25 years
i guess since he did love valor
compassion
and uh and
it was amazing it was an amazing
experience i've never done anything like
that like we did the play for four and a
half months and then we had a year off
and then we came back and did the movie
that is so same cast everybody every
single time
matt bomer jim parsons andrew reynolds
tuck watkins michael benjamin washington
robin dejesus brian hutchinson
i think that's all of us
amazing company of actors all gay all
out
um mantela directed rhymer if you
produced oh and charlie carver um also
amazing and uh yeah it was incredible
incredible experience and uh
and yeah i think it comes i don't know
when it comes out but sometimes sometime
on netflix um yeah that's really cool
and joe i was one of the best theater
directors of god yeah yeah totally i
can't wait and we have joe and i have
this very interesting
our our journeys have overlapped
significantly he originated the role of
lewis and angels in america then i
played lewis in ages
right new york revival
uh i did the glass of measuring on
broadway then he did the same role in
the glass measuring on broadway three
years later oh i didn't know that yeah
we did i did yeah joe played tom in
glasgow with sally field that sam gold
directed uh like three or four seasons
after we did it
weird um and we have personal overlaps
in our lives it's been very interesting
to come you both had long-term
relationships with john robbie bates
oh oh i was kidding no we i i did i was
the first yeah i dated robbie afterwards
and he broke up to it
yeah yeah it's so crazy oh i met joe
actually you're joking no i'm not that's
how i met joe was i was like
dating robbie like we didn't they had a
13-year relationship probably never
together for like nine months but like
you know i'm so sorry i didn't mean to
oh that's true oh my god
joe through robbie at like
odeon
of course
you know robbie was like i want you to
meet joe and like whatever now i'm like
friends i've worked with robbie and what
a small gay world yes small gay world
i'm always so i'm so envious of you guys
because you get to stay friends with
your experts mostly friends with most of
my exes i wish that worked in our
yeah in this trusted world yeah it's
tough it's tough being strong
for you straight people
um well but hopefully we get the right
politicians in and we get more rights
yeah sure i'm so glad we had this me too
i'm grateful that you reached out i
remember
the last time i ran into in l.a outside
of were you birds probably right birds
poop out like walking my dog that's
right and we caught up and did you live
in that area i was staying right there
when i was doing boys in the bands oh
okay but uh but yeah you had mentioned
the podcast and i was like yeah i'd love
to do it and i feel the same way every
time i see you i'm always happy and i
just really appreciate your humor and
your spirit and you're always in a good
good
mood and like yeah it's always just fun
to hang out and connect likewise i'm
glad to thanks buddy be able to do it we
should hang out more we should um let's
do a play together i would love that i'm
ready
uh you're ready to go back oh my god
that's all i want to do yeah i could
only do theater me too that's all i
would do i'd love that man let's do it
too uh okay thank you for doing this man
my pleasure
so that's just
i don't know what that was i don't
either yeah did you try to do a spock
yeah i i it's because spock is so like i
saw your eyes thinking of the way to do
spock you know and i almost went like
this with my hands like a spock and uh i
just saw that i mentioned the
documentary but that is spock has such a
great death scene in um star trek
spoiler alert well now then he comes
back in star trek three also spoiler
alert but in star trek double spoiler
that's rare yeah i got another weird
thoughtful gift once from a girlfriend
she gave me a venus fly trap
and i was like well that's weird but
thoughtful
did i do you you go venus flytrap
with my lips yeah i was sorry i did like
it's hard to explain what you just did
yeah it was like an elvis spasm it was
like uh yeah venus flytrap that's cool i
like venus flytrap i do too but it was
both blue
you know both have to like carnivorous
plants
uh but to answer your question no i
don't i don't think i've ever gotten a
really weird gift like that um
he has a very sage
like
energy yes
i trust everything he says and i want to
you know i just asked him about texting
him about that meditation yeah because i
really think it'd be beneficial i think
you should have uh gotten into it when
judy greer i know i know about it first
i know but now it's like judy greer and
zachary quinto no no no no all of it's
like it's like going to vegas and all of
those it's like god is putting up or
whomever is putting up all of these like
neon signs that are just like almost
like tacky at this point how how obtuse
they are i want to get into it too yeah
it seems obvious seems obvious and like
zach just seemed both of them judy anzac
just seemed like such wise people it is
not that you're not wise but if it
hearing from him it really
i feel the year that he has on you yeah
i mean yeah i know it occurred to me
that i hadn't really hung out with him
much while we were totally sober right
you know we were usually like pretty
stoned he makes a good case for sobriety
great case he really does great yeah and
i know sober people often do
you know it's rare when you hear from a
sober person who's like
yeah selling sobriety on youtube it's
rare to hear that sales pitch and and be
like i don't want that no
he was i thought it was uh interesting
that he used the word grateful that
gratitude is the thing that he that he
lost yeah
um and i and i never would have seen it
that way i would never have thought of
it that way i know but it it it does
make sense when you think about it
because when you're kind of hazed out
all the time yeah and numbed yeah all
the time
it uh it makes it very difficult and
it's difficult to do this in general but
it makes it very difficult even more
difficult to have any real perspective
on your own life you know
um to be able to sort of step back
from your own uh situation
what's happening in your life to have
some sort of objectivity to your life
the good and bad i think the challenge
in that is like knowing that in order to
have that clarity and and in order to
lift that fog that haze that you said
you have to see the bad too right see
the problems and that i think is why a
lot of people continue to abuse because
it's difficult to sit with it yeah sure
life can be i mean especially when you
sit with the
the tragic the more tragic elements of
life it can be really hard and and i
think it's a matter of and zack alluded
to this and other sober friends might
have it's a matter of just
working through
those darker elements that are becoming
equally visible as the gratitude and the
good ones and then having gratitude for
the good the good parts of life and
and there's so many there's so we're so
lucky i i often think that when um and i
i could really relate to that when zach
said that because i often find myself
losing sight of how grateful i am to be
alive and healthy and get to do get to
do what
we love to do especially that's a very
rare
thing right and i think it's especially
problematic which thankfully this has
never happened to me but but i i feel
like i've approached this
this level of um
of usage of whether it be alcohol or
coffee or
weed like when you stop getting high
basically when you don't feel high
anymore or cigarettes i used to smoke
cigarettes a long time ago a long time
ago now if you do enough of it you stop
feeling the positive effects of it right
and it just becomes something you do and
like often something you have to do
because
it's a routine yeah for me i feel that
with coffee like now you don't get that
fun like i know now it's just like
something i have to have i do this and
like this is part of the and i think if
when you get into a habit of smoking too
much weed too
you start to just feel numbed by it and
you don't feel high from it i know and
it's i think it's important to talk
about because we often talk about that
on the flip side we talk about we wax
poetic about how great weed can be and i
do believe that i think it has i mean i
i still i continue to enjoy it and um
but it's it's really worth noting that
it can be abused and and i've seen it in
my own life and i've seen friends of
mine who have changed as a result of
smoking too much of it and it's really
something zach made me
he heightened my awareness of my own
usage right and he did it without any
shame or judgment you know i think
that's the most effective counsel to
have the most
we refer to him as like a white like a
sage yeah i think that's when a sage is
most effective is when they're
approaching something like that with
compassion and understanding and no
judgment yeah no soapbox yeah
uh he also has a much better pittsburgh
accent than you oh yeah yeah
much better
i wish though i wish i had a dialect
coach on um because it's such a great
accent and and hearing him do it it made
me regret certain choices i made with
that character um
just not being more on top of it i in
the character and jerry hodges
plug plus yeah netflix currently on
netflix uh but his was great yeah when
he was talking about
coming out and publicly i thought it was
admirable
i couldn't relate to it at all you know
so because
the obvious the idea being that he is
making this personal sacrifice yes it is
a sacrifice because you don't know how
it's going to be especially for an actor
i mean sure it is for everyone let's
face it but um an actor it it could
potentially alter
how people see him as an actor and the
roles he's he's allowed to of course
undertake but do it he did so because of
the greater good because it's a very
selfless thing of kids who are
doubting and i think he
and someone like neil patrick harris i
think those guys
and other guys there are other examples
of this but those two guys jump to mind
are very important in terms of
norm
normalizing
homosexuality yeah because
meeting them or hearing from them it's
not
apparent what their sexuality is and i
think that fact yeah is very important
yeah you know it's very important making
mainstream audiences totally feel
comfortable and in zach and and neil's
case i think it's
they saw them play these roles that had
nothing really to do with sexuality if
any psychology if anything it was had
more to do with heterosexuality in
neil's case i mean neil on everyone
everyone says i love your mother no how
about your
mother everyone loves raymond's mother
yeah in that case it was that guy was
hyper heterosexual and so and people
fell in love with that character in that
show and it was it was a mainstream hit
so
for neil to then say he's gay after
people had already accepted characters
that he played straight characters that
he played it i think it was a huge
moment and as in zach's case he's
playing this iconic
you know leonard nimoy had had made this
role iconic and and zach picked up the
baton in such an admirable way and and
also found nuances to that character
that hadn't been explored and just to
clarify i don't think breaking that
stigma of like what a gay person sounds
like is
uh
is right necessarily that that had to
happen because i think people should be
able to speak however they want to speak
and should be accepted regardless right
but
the truth is
it's not like right people don't accept
things that are different
right off the bat or uncomfortable to
them right off the bat so i think guys
like that
have provided a bridge for certain
audiences that make them feel more
comfortable even though
i don't think they should have to yeah
but i do think the result has been
important
culturally it was necessary and and they
do feel uncomfortable and there is that
prejudice because like you said there's
just people fear what they don't know
they fear the unknown and that's the
case with i think i think you can
probably link every prejudice to that
it's just perception it's an old
perception altering people's perception
i like how you did your research about
the show that he's on the night before
you like had some facts about it yeah
and you were like is it true
that um tom brady well that is one of
the creators of the show and he was like
yeah that's true yeah yeah tom right
yeah and you're like do you make fun of
them all the time forever the name tom
brady and he was like no i probably did
for the first week or so and you're like
yeah okay and i thought if the roles
were reversed if you were in his
position and tom brady was someone you
knew oh man
not the actual tom brady you would never
let that um you would never let that go
i you would do tom brady bits constantly
tell me i'm wrong well i i i think i'd
do it longer than a week for sure
for sure
but i i like i like to think that if i
got the sense from him that he wasn't
enjoying it or he was like
he was it was hurting his feelings
i don't know i don't know
i love how much he loves emojis how
excited he got by emojis yeah to the
point where ooh he was like oh yeah he
was so excited and he was like he
explained that he had um bitmojis though
you call it when you have a little
avatar of yourself
and you were like oh you use you wear
that um black hat all the time glasses
and he was like yeah my little guy has
that like my back
so i started to think wait does he dress
like his bitmoji it'd be funny if you
like screwed up with your bitmoji and
added like a propeller beanie to it and
then wow sorry i gotta wear that because
i gotta wear that now
um the uh favorite movie question is
often enough now people are
shame you people often shame you right
with it we probably should change that
didn't we talk about i think we are
going to change we're going to change it
but there's part of me because he shamed
me he was like my favorite movie
he was one of like the last four yeah
but see part of me likes the fact that
you get shame for it because
i think it's set not not because i know
shane but i think it's
in a way it says more about a person
than what their favorite movie is
specifically you know the level of
annoyance they feel
about that question yeah is revealing
about them as a person that's true so
i like that about it that's true and
then don't you haven't you realized they
end up answering it in some form right
it's usually like i can't pick just one
one
ten of them and those are usually the
ones that are like alec baldwin i think
gina did it those are the ones that are
really into movies right he said that he
um
if he could be reincarnated as an animal
he said an owl and you go ah i can see
that yeah okay and i can see that too
yeah he is so outlet i would have i
would have guessed that if if someone
had said well what what animal is that
going to remind you of i i probably
would have i may have said owl first he
has owl energy he is sage
wise yes owl energy i would say like a
hawk or an eagle
um but he's more but but he there's more
of a
warmth like a nighttime kind of
sophistication to him too he is
sophisticated yeah that's a really good
word for him he is he's very worldly and
he talked about how much he loves
traveling it makes sense that he
um he's had
so much experience in the world doesn't
it seem like he's really lived life yeah
and
it does he has like he has like he has
um like a calm strength about him yes
and confidence which spock is supposed
to have again another reason why he's
perfect for that
and you know another reason why i think
it's valuable to explore maybe getting
off social media or explore the effects
anyway that social media has um on your
mental well-being is because i think he
came to a lot of these realizations and
he got to this good place because he had
been off social media for a long time
and we talked about it making you feel
like you're
less than or not worthy or
like uncool you're out you're an
outsider and not fitting in fomo fomo
yeah that's what social media does now i
mean that's that's a it must be profound
the effect that it's having on teenagers
who have that can't imagine in spades
anyway that feeling
he was talking about how gay men
tend to be able to stay friends with
each other after they break up and i
wish straight people could do that too
you know and i know most of my gay
friends i can say that about that
if they get out of a relationship they
very very often more often than not
keep that person in their life in some
capacity they they remain friends and
they sometimes they remain very good for
friends i know yeah but that almost
never happens in the straight world it's
unfortunate it is you spend so much time
with someone and you and you get to
share so much you get to know their
families
and then they're like gone often
not only in some cases they're gone but
they're also like
you know there's still so much anger and
vitriol and like it's replaced by this
stuff that like for for no reason really
yeah
it doesn't need but it's like they don't
exist anymore and it's it's really sad i
i envy the gay community me too in that
respect in many respects
but notably in that respect yeah which
just solidifies them as my favorite
community
um all right here's the letter
okay
this is for okay
why am i talking like that okay oh wow
what a great name this is from fawn
i wish i could say her last name but
it's i'm just going to say fawn c
subject new questions oh interesting
hey justin and christian you guys are
the best thank you fawn
uh i love your show you are my favorite
podcast do you know what joke i'm gonna
make
no and she's really fawning over us oh
boy
one suggestion slash request can you
change up the random questions for 2020
ah i like the old ones but i think it's
time for some new i totally agree here's
a few suggestions if you weren't famous
what career would you be in that's a
good one it's a really good one
uh where have you never been that you
would like to go also good
what's one regret you have
these are great if you could uh only
have meat or vegetables what would you
choose happy new year fawn
fawn that is perfect timing because we
were just talking about that and uh yeah
we are one that we want to do uh one new
one and those are we should do that i
definitely like that there are a couple
that were we want to change up yeah uh
not in time for the new year we missed
that boat but i would say starting next
episode we're going to start to replace
maybe some of the questions yes um
and we want to mostly keep it a surprise
but one question will be
which golden girl do you identify with
which golden girl are you yeah we like
that one because we've been thinking
about it they're such different similar
to the muppet question i suppose but
they are
they they represent such different type
sets different personalities but i i
really like fawn's suggestion if you
weren't famous what career were that
yeah there's some good ones we're gonna
take this under advice yes
strongly consider this and the one i
don't get at first is
if you had to pick meat or vegetables
what would you pick just meat or just
special if you had an all meat diet
first of all you would get
like three days yeah that's like gout
goals um so i guess you would have to
save just vegetables yeah and also for
the environment you wouldn't survive if
you had just you'd also be an [ __ ]
i mean
you it would be so bad for the invite
it'd be so good for the environment if
you just ate vegetables it's something i
want to do more of so that's an easy one
we're not going to use that one no we're
not going to use that but um we also had
another one uh because
we had one that we may end up using we
may not but it was um would you rather
be called uh would you rather somebody
think you were ugly or unattractive or
unfunny
and and that came about because somebody
on instagram
uh
called me fugly they didn't call you
fugly but they said [ __ ] just oh yeah
they said [ __ ] justin long i don't
think they meant fugly
you do think that because then their
friend whom they tagged was like i'm
sorry but i like him he's my crush
whatever
meaning
which which i think i don't think that
means that automatically i think it
could mean like [ __ ] [ __ ] justin
long i'm sick of that guy or well that's
even that might be worse all right well
now i know your answer would you okay
that's a good one would you rather
somebody just be sick of you because you
annoyed them or if they they find you
[ __ ] ugly
uh i'd rather them be it depends who it
is
all right that's true okay well that's
the show on that this week guys uh
what would you rather uh think about
that and um
and get back to us and if you want to
write us about that or anything else uh
feel free to do so at
lifeisshortwondery.com thank you to
zachary quinto for
being justin's impressive birthday buddy
and thanks to everyone who listened and
uh shout out to all the other june 2nd
birthday buddies and uh chris and all
the september 6th buddies and uh shout
out to all the shorties and all the
people listening thank you so we'll see
you guys next week
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by virgo christian
long also produced by uh megan monaco
senior producer is michelle
miesh lance
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marsha louie
also has a birthday and hernan lopez
birthday tbd maybe an aquarius
probably we'll see you guys next week
oh
[Music]
and he takes people's eyes out yeah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
[Music]
what was it called
he takes me in his eyes so it's like
[Music]
i'm a little sick
you